jonas geht hier zu erkennen wir spielen
heute sky awards zusammen mit jonas
china was geht
ich muss den tod ich bin heute eine
runde scores zusammen mit jona fickus
hallo ich hab's geschafft die mitte
first drei freunde ihr wisst ja dass ich
mir noch ganz viele kisten ja oh gott
hat es jemand was ich bin und herzlich
willkommen zum ersten aufnahme versucht
man muss sich erstmal ein teenager bauen
ganz auch nicht 300.000 blöcke die
tabelle werfen männer kann ich das nicht
so das sieht jeder blinder dass man da
nicht dass man da nicht hinwerfen kann
jetzt bei schachtjor ok schnell luther
lu toyota luthe
der war klasse
wir kamen dann greifen wir diesen typen
hier an ob er bei diesem ganz
gewalttätig und gemein die hier vorne
hast du das spiel ja das hätte jonas
nicht mal lust habe ein
klassische maschine wer kennt ihn nicht
jona fische ak der rasierer ak lister
ich treffe mit jeder ändert wäre sofort
mein ziel
acciona ab juni dann hast du noch ein
spinnennetz blogs platzieren platziere
dieses blocks am besten nicht da bin ich
genauso wie man eine angel kräften ob es
überhaupt geht
erfreulich finde ich hier wie man eine
kräftige
ok
ist freilich haben
hatte
mit funktionieren soll
ich kann keine angebrachten es tut mir
so leid freude beleidigt hätten nichts
zu tun
oder vielleicht wird er einfach
herausgestellt mittels rausgestellt jona
weißen haus geht
wenn es da nicht anders gestellt
tja leute in konstanz youtube sparkurs
wie könnte ich mein spiel gegen ahnung
hatte ich aber hoch und die sind viel
besser als wir
aber wie sagt man so schön in unserem
schönen land jolo geht weiter runter
hast du tt.com auch schnell reporter
tsch 1
der andere
deshalb fordert als ob ich könnte sie
morgen wieder 2 ich bin der mitte
geworfen
warum
okay dass seine mir das meiste aber
darauf
mit soja warten so freundlich problem
allein fertig zu spielen die runde
die umstände erfordern es irgendwie dass
ich das alleine probiere ich habe viel
verständnis wenn ich mal so ich geh ja
zu ich habe auch nicht so optimal
gespielt bisher aber jona durchgespielt
so scheiße wie hey du hättest du hättest
du internet eigentlich nicht wie macht
man minecraft magst du meine minecraft
videos etwa geringer
oder war es einfach nur leere worte
gerade warum hättest du im internet
alter so leid
wieso
hättest du im internet alter ich muss ja
nur die den anfang rausschneiden jeweils
jona ist es keine zeit gemütlichkeit in
meinen aufnahmen
das machen wir hier nicht sinkt so da
sagst du musst also ich liebe ja leute
die einfach mal die wahrheit sagen und
du bist einfach so ein und deshalb liebe
ich nicht so sehr habe ich den typen da
unten auszuräuchern oder ist ja schon
tot
herr jonah nicht kosten
hey freundchen mist jetzt ist der weg
abgebaut
verdammt
big save ich mache jetzt voll unnötig
eigentlich du kannst dich
ich bin kurz davor dieses videospiel mit
einem lupfer 2 zu machen
aber die umstände erfordern es einfach
zu mir leid ich will irgendwas kurs mit
ihren themen frauen führe ich merke
jetzt vielleicht auch nicht aber
höchstwahrscheinlich doch das ist
einfach so bezeichnend für dieses ganze
video offenbar leute okay ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen
wir sehen zwar nächsten mal wieder ich
glaube das war kein zufall ist dass er
schreibt maul yamauchi